[Música]
bienvenidos a esta edición de enlace
centroamérica desde panamá hoy
hablaremos del tránsito de inmigrantes
tras un año 2021 récord de flujo
migratorio que superó las 133 mil
personas que atravesaron el exmo rumbo a
eeuu veremos como la realidad particular
de cada una de esas personas puede tener
un impacto en la economía de pequeña
escala también nos detendremos en el
canal de panamá donde pasa el 6% del
comercio mundial y revisaremos cómo la
crisis global de contenedores como
consecuencia de la pandemia terminó
impactando positivamente la ruta
transoceánica
por último conoceremos el job
humanitario que atiende las emergencias
y desastres naturales en prácticamente
toda la región cuando un migrante ha
pisado suelo panameño ha logrado superar
el difícil reto que representa la selva
del darién le espera el recorrido de una
frontera a otra que ahora deja de ser
hostil el istmo es una parada de la ruta
mientras llega la ayuda económica de
amigos o familiares para continuar al
norte del continente
en este centro de remesas a minutos de
la frontera con costa rica claudia de
nacionalidad cubana espera recibir algo
de efectivo junto a su hijo y su esposo
han caminado durante un mes desde chile
no lleva la cuenta de sus gastos pero
estima que alcanzan los tres mil dólares
entre alimentación estadía y transporte
en cada país de paso ya en el momento en
el que necesitas empezar a recibir ayuda
económica de tus familiares para poder
seguir avanzando a raíz de eso mismo de
que no te cobras lo que deberían cobrar
te sino que empiezan a alterar te los
precios y entonces terminas pagando de
más el dinero te empieza a alcanzar
menos entonces la necesidad y mucho más
cuando andas con un niño pequeño a pocos
kilómetros del lugar en las afueras del
albergue de los planes de gualaca un
grupo de familias han hecho del comercio
informal para migrantes subsistente
oleada migratoria récord de 2021
significa una ayuda económica en medio
de la pandemia ahora el flujo de
migrantes es menor pero ángel contreras
es un joven de 20 años recuerda que en
el peor momento de la pandemia ganaba
hasta 175 dólares
instalando chips en losers cuando inicie
aquí no lo veía tanto como una ayuda
sino más bien como el beneficio
económico sin embargo al pasar los días
al pasar todas las jornadas que pasaba
aquí he podido comprender que realmente
las cosas van más allá del dinero según
cifras del banco interamericano de
desarrollo sólo en américa latina' el
último año circularon más de 120 mil
millones de dólares por concepto de
remesas en panamá se recibieron 377
millones de dólares entre enero y
septiembre de 2021 en época de verano 35
buques en promedio transitan a diario
por el canal de panamá
eventualmente esa cifra puede subir
cuando aumenta el número de barcos en
espera es lo que ha ocurrido en estos
últimos meses producto de la crisis
global de los contenedores este punto
conecta a los puertos asiáticos de la
costa de este de los eeuu pacífico y
atlántico de sudamérica el impacto de la
crisis de transporte marítimo global ha
sido positivo para esta ruta
alrededor de 100 buques hacen fila en la
bahía de panamá de hecho 2 % fue el
aumento del número de portacontenedores
y 10% la carga de portacontenedores
durante todo el año 2021
comparativamente se acerca también a lo
que ocurrió con el canal de suez que
tuvo un incremento de 7.2 por ciento en
el número de contenedores la ampliación
del canal de panamá en 2016 sirvió para
esta circunstancia al abrir el paso a
buques de más de 15 mil contenedores
cuando antes sólo podían pasar
embarcaciones con 5000 contenedores a lo
que fue
digamos que movió la ampliación no era
solamente aumentar el número de tránsito
sino buques más grandes que pasan mucho
más mercancía y entonces son menos
tránsitos que tienen que pasar mientras
más grande el buque para nosotros mejor
lo que queremos es buques grandes más
que muchos buques porque consumen más
agua o sea que él aunque hemos mantenido
un número de 13.000 tránsitos en los
últimos digamos 10 años
tres oscilando trece mil 313 mil
quinientos en lo que ha aumentado mucho
el tonelaje de 300 habitantes millones
de toneladas a más de 516 millones de
toneladas desde este punto del
continente la respuesta ante cualquier
emergencia o desastre natural en la
región puede ser de 24 a 48 horas por
eso la cruz roja internacional y el
depósito de respuesta humanitaria de las
naciones unidas utilizan a panamá como
plataforma para las américas más de 3
mil toneladas se movieron desde estos
depósitos durante el año 2021 uno de los
países donde más hemos intervenido en
los últimos años podríamos mencionar
haití las islas del caribe por la
frecuencia y el riesgo que tienen
impacto de huracanes y tormentas en la
temporada huracanes año pero también
atendemos países de suramérica
centroamérica desde este galpón se llevó
a cabo la mayor movilización humanitaria
en la región por parte de naciones
unidas para atender la pandemia desde
aquí se atendió prácticamente a todos
los países del continente salvo eeuu
méxico canadá y puerto rico el hobo
humanitario oficialmente inaugurado en
2018 sigue fortaleciendo la plataforma
logística de panamá pero también ha
puesto en circulación el territorio
canalero más de 60 millones de dólares
al menos el último año está previsto que
puede aumentar su espacio 3 100 veces
más de la cobertura actual gracias por
acompañarnos en este enlace
centroamérica desde panamá soy oscar
sulbarán y le invito a seguir con más de
francés 24 en español